même après la mort
l'Union soviétique n'est rien d'autre
la Russie historique ne s'appelait
différemment mais contenu idéologique
l'état était bien sûr différent, mais avec
point de vue géopolitique
la Russie historique même après
un tiers du potentiel a tout perdu
La Russie est trop grande pour certains
mais vraiment le potentiel est colossal
le territoire reste le plus grand du monde
146 millions de personnes semblent avoir tort
beaucoup par rapport aux pays où
des centaines de millions de citoyens vivent et même
pour un trillion pour un milliard vient déjà ici
mais ça compte quand même beaucoup
certains osent même publiquement
dire que c'est injuste
La Russie possède la richesse de tels
région comme imaginez un seul pays mais
étrange d'entendre de telles choses surtout
public mais ils sonnent parfois c'est tout
ils veulent nous mordre quelque part ou quelque chose de
nous mordre mais ils devraient savoir ceux qui
on va faire ça on s'est cassé les dents
tout le monde pour qu'ils ne puissent pas mordre
c'est une évidence et la garantie de ce développement
nos forces armées